in this video we'll be talking about
tripurite Synapse when we think about
Synapse this is the picture that comes
in our head neurons connecting with
other neurons in the brain but this
picture is rather incomplete because
besides neuron there are other players
such as the astrocytes
so astrocytes along with the neuron
actually form
the tripartite synapse
and in this tripartite synapse a lot of
things happen in this video we would
quickly learn about tripartite Synapse
one of the thing that astrocytes
regulate in the tripartite synapse is
the utilization and biosynthesis of a
neurotransmitter known as glutamate
so let us look at how astrocyte can
modulate the glutamate glutamine cycle
in the tripodite synapse so imagine this
is a glutamatergic synapse this is the
pre synapse this is the post synapse and
here in the pink is the astrocyte
so in the prison apps when the action
potential comes there should be release
of glutamate into the synaptic lift
so where does glutamate come from but
before that let me tell you the
glutamate which is released would bind
to the postsynaptic glutamate receptors
now glutamate gets synthesized from
glutamine
and this happens via the enzyme
glutaminase
then
astrocyte actually provides this
glutamine to the neurons eventually this
glutamate once produced is loaded by
specific vesicular glutamate
Transporters into synaptic vesicles
and when the action potential comes
these vesicles can be released
now when there is excess amount of
glutamate present in the synaptic cleft
there are excitatory amino acid
Transporters which can take up the
excess glutamate and these Transporters
are present in mostly in astrocytes so
astrocyte can mop up extra amount of
glutamate present in the synaptic lift
once uptaken this glutamate can be
converted into glutamine with the help
of glutamine synthetase enzyme
so this particular function is really
important for neuronal functioning
because too much glutamate is bad for
the neuron it can lead to excitotoxicity
and which ultimately lead to the death
of the neurons
so glutamate excited toxicity is
prevented by the proper functioning of
these important glial cell known as
astrocytes because they take up extra
glutamate
now besides mopping up glutamate or
helping in the glutamate biosynthesis
pathway astrocytes are far more
important and they play a further
important role in the brain it turns out
in the tripartite synapse astrocyte can
secrete specific molecules which help in
neuronal communication and these
molecules are known as gliotransmitters
which are shown here by Red
neurotransmitter are in black and
gliotransmitters are shown in the red
so these gliotransmitters are actually
interpreted by the synapse via specific
receptors and thereby astrocyte can
actually communicate with a functional
synapse if these tripartite synapse are
perturbed this would lead to many
disease including neurodegenerative
disorders so I hope this was useful if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up you can get more flash card
and notes in our Facebook and Instagram
page
you can support our Channel using super
thanks you can pay via paytm PayPal or
UPI
so see you in next video